I'm Natalie mean yes on behalf of
talks at Google or Liberia chapter and
Hispanic heritage month.
We welcome you and thank you so much for
being here as well as everyone in the
audience. Um, we're very
honored to have him. Phenomenal.
Thank you.
Give a
so
for all the people in the audience and
those who are live streaming in a little
bit about Uv sub,
you've written 23 bucks and it's
been translated into 35 languages.
You've your words of literally reached
across all ends of the earth and have
been adapted into movies
and ballets and plays. Um,
and we're just very excited to see
what more you have in store for us.
You've received the
highest civilian honor,
the medal of freedom by
former president Barack Obama.
You've actually carried the torch in
the Olympics and the Winter Olympics.
I was out,
done any sports in my life,
nothing.
I can't even walk and I had to
carry the flag and the Olympic.
Thanks.
Go figure.
We were happy to have you represent
Latino Medica and women all over the world
and that,
um,
you've received a lot of honor awards
and honorary doctorates from universities
and very,
very successful
for someone who high, hardly finished
high school. Well those honorary degree
received very ironic.
Yeah.
It's to say that we shouldn't have
gone to high school, but um, no,
we're,
we're absolutely thrilled about all the
works that you've given us to the world.
Um, and you continue to give back.
You give yourself back with your,
the sub l again,
the foundation that empowers women
and girls and all throughout cheating
California and were amazed by the words
that you have for us and the actions
that you continue to give.
Thank you. Thank you.
So I think would like to start
with, um, but from the beginning,
from like how you became the person you
became, someone born, a girl born in Peru,
which lane girl born in Peru and came
here and had stories of love and mystery
and coincidence is, can you
tell us a little while? Um,
I wasn't planning to be a writer really.
I was born in the middle
of the second war,
world war in a very conservative,
Catholic,
patriarchal environment.
And I was supposed to be somebody's wife,
somebody's mother.
It didn't work out for me.
I didn't have the raw material
for that job. I, no, not at all.
So I was very rebellious.
Even when I was very young,
I sort of realized that being a woman
was not to my advantage because I saw my
mom, I saw that my momma in
the household where we lived,
we lived with my
grandfather and my uncles.
The males had all the privileges and the
W my mother, who was the woman, didn't, I,
she didn't have any money and
she didn't have any independence.
I didn't want to be like her.
So I think I became a feminist around
age five before that word was invented in
Chile. And then, um,
I became a journalist until
it worked as a journalist.
I did everything except radio.
I did television, newspapers,
magazines, you name it.
And then we had a military coup in Chile
in 1973 and very soon I had to get out
of my country.
And I went as a political
refugee to Venezuela where
I could not find a job as a
journalist.
So I worked in all kinds of odd jobs
to make a living and support my kids,
two kids and at least one dog.
And um,
and then by 1981,
I was working,
administering a school in Caracas.
That was not the job for me.
I can't even add or subtract.
And I had to deal with checkbooks and
with money and it was just a total
disaster.
But they get me for like four years.
And during that time in 1981,
I got a phone call that my
grandfather whom I adored,
was dying and I could not return to
my country to beat him farewell. So I,
um, I started a letter, which
was like a spiritual letter.
I would write to him often,
but this was a different letter because
I wasn't sure if he was going to be able
to read it.
And I wanted to tell him that all
the stories that he had told me,
and he was a wonderful storyteller.
I remembered them,
I had them all with me. It was my,
they represented my background,
my roots, my family, everything
that I had left behind.
And I think that in a way,
as a political refugee,
I felt an overwhelming nostalgia. You,
you sort of idealize the
country that you left.
There's a reason why you left
because you couldn't live there,
but still one idea license it.
And the idea is to try to go
back all the time. So, um,
the letter from my grandfather was
about the stories that he had told me.
And the first story was a
story of my aunt Rosa. My,
my great aunt Rosa was my grandfather's
first fiancee and she died in mysterious
circumstances before
they could get married.
So eight years later,
he married the youngest daughter in the
same family with the idea that if he had
been accepted once,
he would be accepted the second time too.
So that's why he married my grandmother
who nobody wanted to marry because he
was so weird. She was, she was
adorable, but totally weird.
She knew she lived in another world.
She was always experimenting
with the paranormal.
So my first few years were with this
wonderful grandmother and there was a
table,
a very heavy Spanish table
where my grandmother would
have the same answers and
she would call the spirits with a table
and they say that the table would jump
twice for years.
One for now I have the table in my house.
I've tried to
everything you need to men to the table.
So I don't know how she did it,
but there must've been some trick
there. So with that
background, with that family,
I think that it also only natural
that I would have to write about it,
about that grandmother who is
clad in the house of the spirits.
My first novel.
So the idea was to tell my grandfather
that I remembered what he had told me on
the first story in the letter
was a story of my aunt Rosa,
my great aunt Rosa.
And then I kept on driving.
He died and I couldn't stop.
And it wasn't the memories of the family,
things that I invented that I made up
and the history of my country for 17
years.
So it wasn't micro world of the family
that reflected the macro world of the
country. And so that's the
house of the spirits. Of course,
I didn't plan it that way.
It just happened later in this book was
written 35 years ago and now that the
book has been studied and whatever,
people tell me all this
because I didn't plan it,
you asked me what the book is about.
I'm telling you what the reviewers upset,
not what I had in mind.
So knowing now the reach
that that book has had,
would you have done anything differently?
Would you have?
Well, you know, I was,
we were talking in the car that I never
read my books because there's so much
that you can correct. You
can correct forever. Well,
it saw what it was.
Okay.
At the time is totally
politically incorrect today.
There are certain terms or certain
things that you can say today,
not even in Chile.
In Chile,
we have very little idea of what
politically correct is in Venezuela.
Even less. But, uh,
but still there are things that you
don't say anymore in this century that we
live in today.
Too Bad,
we're very colorful actually.
Do you think,
do you think that the Spanish language,
um,
has morphed the way that you think in
terms of femininity and masculinity?
And as that's being translated
to these other books,
is there anything that's
lost in translation?
Well,
as we all know in the Spanish language,
you cannot change everything.
Every,
every adjective has gender because
it applies to a now that has gender,
which doesn't happen in English.
So for example,
I have a granddaughter who is
into the LGBT, et Cetera, and she,
um,
she has asked me to change the pronouns
in English being the second language.
For me it's pretty hard.
But to translate that into Spanish is
almost impossible because every adjective
would have gender. And so I can't
handle it in Spanish that well.
In that sense, it's a very different
language. The other thing with,
with Spanish also is that it is a
less flexible language than English.
In English, everything can be turned
into a verb. You can add other words.
You can put words together in
wonderful ways. Spanish is very strict,
so you have to stick to
grammar and spelling of course.
And you've been called the most widely
read Spanish language author and you have
got a CMR kiss and Jose,
um,
and so many other amazing authors.
Now that you see your name among those,
does it change the way you
approached new books and new stories?
No, it doesn't because I
tried to write from the womb,
from the brain so much and I
tried to write the best I can,
whatever the critics say or how many
books are sold or if they are compared to
somebody else's writing. I
can't worry about that. And uh,
I don't even read the
reviews because I get either,
I would say I get influenced.
I don't get upset because I understand
that if you do anything in public what we
do, people will criticize you. Some people
will like you or some people will not.
And I have to be ready for that.
So I don't get all
upset because something is bad and I
don't celebrate too much when something is
good because everything passes,
it doesn't matter in the long run,
nothing matters.
And out of all these authors like Jose
Donoso and Garcia Marquez, was there any,
any one off there that influenced
you and that you looked up to?
I was in my late teens,
early twenties when I started reading
the big names of the boom of Latin
American literature,
at least 25 all male.
Many of them would mustache man
who wrote this fantastic books.
They were different books in
different countries of Latin America,
but all of them was formed as sort of
harmonic choir of that that you know,
in a way,
told the world what Latin America was
about and told us who we were as a whole.
So I grew up reading them.
Yes. And did you ever know, you know,
being them male authors,
was there anything about you that you
wanted to share differently that would
impact Latino literature?
I didn't plan it.
I didn't think that way.
I just wrote what I knew and had been
working for women and with women and being
a woman all my life.
So,
so it was only natural that my protagonist
would tend to be more female than
male. So when, when my book, the
House of the spirits was published,
they said that I was the only
female voice in the boom at then.
They rapidly said, no, she doesn't
belong to the boom. She's possible.
They didn't want a female in
the boom of course. So, um,
so I'm possible whatever posters and um,
I never compared my writing to
what they wrote other people did,
but I don't,
you're writing was definitely influential
to too many other authors after
is that because my book was so
successful that even from the,
from the start publishers all over,
not only in Spain but all over
realize that there is, um,
a readership of feminine readership
that wants to read female voices.
So there was a market for,
for,
for female authors that before
they had not maybe noticed.
Yeah.
And so in a way,
that book opened the door for
other women to be published.
And I feel very proud of that.
Well, yeah. And within these books you'd
have powerful women, powerful women.
Are these women portrayed and from
real life people in your life?
Do you know any weak women?
I do not
know.
I just pick up
people in the street and people,
women that I know through the foundation,
extraordinary women who are survivors
of sometimes the most horrible trauma,
and they not only survived,
they become leaders in their communities.
So that kind of of person,
if a woman or man,
it's always fascinating. Yeah. And,
and I'm always attracted
to those people who are,
who stand outside the big
umbrella of the establishment,
immigrants,
refugees,
and people who have other gender choices.
People who are come from different races,
from different ages.
I've been writing a lot about very
old people and some readers say,
why do you write all these
people who don't even read?
Because they can't even breed.
No, I, I'm interested always in,
in what is outside. Yes.
Not the main stream.
So including these diverse characters,
of course,
there's a part of magic to
it that Magic's not normal.
You don't see that every day.
And well, let's, let's, yeah,
let's imagine to you, magic to
me, or I guess the way I was,
I was phrasing it is, you know, the
fire and the poof in the, you know,
out there, but, but the magic that you
see in the night reading your books
is natural,
is in the one in the room.
What I understand is that we know nothing.
Maybe you hear hearing Google are, you
know, more, but, but normal people,
normal people know very little.
Uh,
normal people have very little control
over their lives and everything that
stands outside that control,
that explanation of life is mysterious.
And some in some cultures like American,
many play places in Europe
who would, you don't, would,
you cannot explain what you're going
to control and what you cannot sell,
you ignore. It's not in the
realm of reality. However,
in most of the world, and I would say
all of Latin America, all of Africa,
all of Asia,
we understand that there are dimensions
of reality that we don't control them.
We don't understand it, but we accept
them. For example, in everybody's lives,
they are coincidences. Those
moments in which you, you think,
I have been here before and you,
I know this place and you know
that you have never been there,
but somehow it's familiar or a person
that you meet and you have the idea that
you've met that person before or I am
thinking of someone on the phone rings and
it's that person that kind of,
or dreams,
that kind of thing that
happens in everybody's life.
You all ignore it because you
don't need it. But, but in my life,
in my country, my culture, you use it,
you use it in everyday life. It becomes
part of, it's integrated to life.
For example,
my,
my mom died two weeks ago and she,
she was wonderful and we had a very close
relationship and she would write to me
every single day and I wrote to her
every day for four years or more.
So I have 40 years of letters in boxes.
Every box has between 600 and 800 letters.
So multiply by 40 I can't multiply,
but you can Google it.
It's a lot.
And now that she's gone,
I thought, well, why can't I write to her?
Maybe she cannot write to me anymore,
but I can try to her. Why not?
And so then I started writing to her
and establishing a connection that is
perfectly natural to me.
And I know that,
that if I write about it in a novel,
it would be either crazy or magic realism.
It's just life.
It's a d like when people say that
your work is part of magic realism.
I think that my work is very realistic.
It just accepts what is mysterious,
but it's very realistic. You know,
Garcia Marquez, the master of
magic realism explains it very,
very wonderfully.
He says that in his book a
hundred years of solitude,
he has Romaleos, Labeija,
Eh, rises to heaven in, in,
in body and soul.
The original stories that in the village
where he lived in the town where he
lived,
a girl had got the air girl got pregnant
and the family made it disappears,
centers centered away.
And the explanation the family gave
was rose to heaven in Seoul and,
and body like the Virgin Mary.
And nobody asked more questions because
everybody understood that no questions
were accepted. But when he wrote
that in the book, it didn't,
it didn't work.
And he said he wrote it several times
and he'd never worked until he had her
hanging the sheets to dry and a winter
came and lifted her with the sheets.
And then there is sort of explanation,
you know,
it's a parachute that elevated
her with a sheets is magic.
Real listen without the sheets
is fantasy like Harry Potter.
Hmm. It, yes. It is interesting.
And it's interesting to hear that magic
realism within the Latino literature is
almost easier to understand because we
have, you know, spirits and we believe in,
but we have spirits here too. I mean,
all my friends see psychics, they
please start here. They see
the whore horoscope. Everybody
has a sign. I mean, yeah.
Sodiank sign or whatever.
So what's the difference? It has a
different name. Yeah. That's interesting.
And do you do speak to them about that?
Like do you connect those spirits
into the, into the Latino community?
Meaning for those that go to psychics and,
um,
before we go to psychics to oh,
that's right. That's right. Yeah.
Is there a way that you
use this to impact, um,
Latino literature are not Latino
literature, but literature globally,
like this idea of, of everybody
believes in the same things. It is.
They're wonderful literary devices.
When you can't solve something, you,
you introduce a psychic
and it's wonderful.
The only time that it didn't work for me,
I was writing a crime
novel and in a crime novel,
everything needs to fit so I couldn't
introduce it. Astronomer, other psychic.
Unfortunate.
Sure. So, um,
I'm curious because you've had a lot of
impact and not just Latino literature,
global literature in representing the
Latino Culture in Tulane culture and
history, how do you see that this is
impacting others and seeing, you know,
Chilean history and books and those,
I don't know if how it
impacts how this, but, but um,
I hope it does because I try to,
what I have written several
historical novels and,
well, when you write fiction, you
have more freedom of course. And that,
that's wonderful.
But I tried to present an event,
historical event from the perspective,
from another eye, not the perspective
of the winners. For example,
I have a novel,
a novel called Island beneath the sea,
and it is about the slave revolt in Haiti.
And of course all the history
books were written by white men,
French or American or whatever,
winners. The winners always.
We never have the perspective of the,
of the, the poor people, the slaves,
the people of color,
the children,
the people who really
experienced the event.
So that's where I try to stand
as a writer and as an observer.
When I research for,
for a historical novel,
I go to if possible,
to pry the documents because
if I read the history books,
that's the official history.
And I want the other history,
what people were saying in their letters.
I have a, an oval about the gold rush.
We all know the gold rush
because we've read about it here,
written by the 40 niners or the people
who follow the 40 niners but long before
the 49 or so arrived, people of
color were here, native Americans,
Mexicans, Peruvians, Chileans.
We were all in the minds before and
that those voices have been obliterated.
They don't exist. And the women
who came also, they don't exist.
So in that,
for that book,
I went to the library in Chile to research
letters that Chilean miners wrote to
their families in Chile in 1850. So, uh,
I got a perspective from,
from another angle,
but we never hear in the United States.
Yeah,
that's interesting to hear that letters,
the stories, the stories, stories,
a person in a, in a letter for
example, someone can explain that. Um,
Eh,
a bottle of champagne was
cheaper than a glass of milk.
You never see that in a history book.
And the reason is that there
was no one to make the cows.
They were all looking for gold and at
champagne came in ships from France.
So that was available.
Interesting. So here at Google, um,
similar to you being a storyteller
and expanding the stories,
reached to people around the globe.
We write code and we make products and
try to make these products accessible to
the world. How do you see
Google being our, you know,
yourself in reaching out to these greater
audiences with stories that had these
little details that aren't
communicated in other ways? Yeah,
I love the process of building a universe
of details that it is in the details
that you get the,
the setting,
the theater where the characters move and
the more details I can find to make it
believable, then the better
that the reader will believe.
The unbelievable,
which is the fiction.
So I create fictional characters that
move in a real world and that makes it
more believable for the reader.
Now,
how that reaches other cultures,
I don't know.
But I love when I read a book,
for example,
written by an Indian author and I
can see how life is in India for,
for that group of people and
learn about them or it's,
I find it fascinating.
And do these stories impact your stories,
stories from all over the world? I
mean, you don't, you my latest book,
um,
what's the name?
What's your latest book?
And I forgot Laurie,
in the midst of winter. Sorry,
because this is a memoir, right? No,
it's not that my leg,
my latest book is fiction and I forgot
the name because I write in Spanish and I
remember everything in Spanish.
I can't remember anything in English,
and in that book I have a character
that is what the Marlin undocumented
migrants,
she's a refugee and she's running away
from the gangs in her country that they
have exterminated her family.
I didn't have to invent that character.
I had to reconstruct her world, but
that character, we have cases like that.
In my foundation, we work with
refugees and a story like that.
I don't have to create the story.
I just have to recreate the village,
the house, the grandmother,
the food, the market,
the voyage,
traveling,
all the way from what the Amala Gross
Mexico to come to the United States,
the border living in clandestine it
in the United States, undocumented.
That's the world I need to construct
very carefully and sticking to the truth
because if I can be very
believable in that aspect,
then the character of Evelyn
Ortega will emerge as real.
And in sharing these stories of other
people and you have memories of your own
life and line and recent one,
is there a difference in the way you go
about writing other stories versus your
own story? Yeah, Eh,
when I write a memoir,
I'm not writing about me alone.
I wrote about me and the people who
are around me, my family friends,
and I asked myself,
is this my story to tell?
Am I betraying someone if I have to
choose between betraying my mother or
telling the story, I tell
the story. Yeah, I can't.
I can't a system, I tell the
story, but I understand that,
that there is a limit to how
much, so my, my way of handling,
when I write a memoir first the
problem is I write in Spanish,
but once it's translated or
I have this sort of idea, I,
I show it to the people who
are named by name in the book.
And if they don't approve, I
take them out. I don't change it,
but I think I take them out. It
has happened only once. And I,
with the latest memoir that
I wrote a long time ago,
I promised my son that I
will never write another one.
And I have so much has
happened since then.
I have so much to tell and I can't
because I promised Nico I wouldn't.
Hmm. So you have your
family here or your, um,
your son having your family near and,
and having your mother
be a huge inspiration.
Does that come across very well in the
love that like Latinos usually, you know,
very communalistic, uh, community.
Yeah. But I don't have the
extended family. You know,
I've tried to put together an extended
family and it worked for a while when my
grand children were little.
We sort of adopted friends with their
children that were part of this almost
compound where we lived.
And uh,
kids would come to the pool. It would
be an open house, always open house.
And I had the feeling that I belonged
in that little tribe where we all belong
in Latin America,
but now all that is gone.
The grandchildren are older.
They have gone to college,
they finish college, they have their own
lives. They don't remember me at all.
You can adopt me. Yeah. Yeah. Good.
And so, um, I like you're saying,
a lot of us have immigrated
over and there's been a
consistent or the bureau, um,
consensus just recently in
the seventies and eighties,
started using the term
Hispanic, Latino. Um,
and we've been here long before then,
so in,
but we're still kind of creating our
identity within the United States.
How do you think is created already?
And so how do you see us showing
to the world that you don't?
We've been here long before anyone else
and you know,
I don't think it matters.
I don't think it matters who came first
because we all came from somewhere else.
Yeah.
Except native Americans.
Every single person who lives in this
country has some ancestor that comes from
another place.
So who came first or who came
second is not that important.
I think that what is important is how we
sort of blend into the culture without
losing our identity.
And we contribute or not to court.
This is this large country made of
so many different colors and voices.
So it is the diversity that
makes the United States so,
so powerful and so unique.
It took country created on an idea,
most emerge historically
out of circumstances,
geography,
um,
tribes that get together or
not language that is common,
but the United States was created with
an idea and the idea of the founding
fathers was very clear.
And it's a country that with those
ideas has been so powerful and so,
so important in the world.
And we tend to forget what made
this country so extraordinary.
The ideas,
the values,
the principles in which the country was
built and the people who came from all
over the world,
all that is so important to keep going,
to keep being what we are.
Yeah.
That's inspiration on.
And we're very excited to continue to
build and show the world our identity from
these, you know, the American
dream of coming here. Um, yeah,
but the American dream is not white
supremacy and its diversity. No,
it is all of us. Absolutely. Yeah. Um,
I have one funny question then since we're
here at willow. We did read question.
Yes. Yes. Have you, um,
have you ever googled yourself and
no. No. Never googled yourself?
I hadn't thought about it. One.
Interesting. Maybe we should try to,
would I did Google like guy? Um, yeah,
that's the only time
I've googled me buddy.
I was,
um,
I separated from my husband
after 28 years of marriage.
I'm in good terms.
It wasn't something awful at all,
but I was in a sort of dark mood because
I was 73 years old and I thought the
rest of my life I'll be alone
sleeping alone with my dog. Not Nice.
Not that my daughter, no,
no, my dog is nice. And um,
and then a guy out of the
blue started emailing me
and there are a few stockers,
but not many. As you get older,
the stockers diminish number.
Um, I saw, he started emailing
me and then I googled him.
But I had a wonderful assistant, Shandra
who was like, like Sherlock Holmes.
She could get in Google. And yet,
I mean the brand of underwear,
every everything. So by that time
I met the guy five months later,
I knew absolutely everything about
his life, his family, his kids,
his car, everything. Wow.
So Google has a big dollar all the time
that I have used to Google for that.
Well, thank you so much. I think at
this time we'd love to open up the,
that will be great.
The floor to questions from the audience
and we'll have to Google yourself.
Sometimes he won't care.
So he's interesting and sometimes
flattering or I'm sure with you often,
I'm sure it's not flattering when
you start seeing your pictures. Yes.
Hi, my name Monica. And um,
you used the word blend
in an interesting way.
Um,
blend to sort of blend
culturally so that um,
we're, you know, we're seeing for who
we are and how we are. The way that,
that I've experienced blending as a
Latina and trying to fit in is in contrast
to how you described it.
And I'd like to know,
have you had experiences of trying to
blend that have been at compromise or at
odds to who you are?
Well,
sometimes I asked to speak to
Latino youth mostly who feel,
who are either calm recently or they
descend from Latino parents who speak
Spanish at home.
So it's a very Latino culture
at home and they feel outside,
like outsiders.
They feel that they are not the blonde
kid with blue eyes that is popular at
school.
And I keep telling them,
you don't have to let go of anything.
You can have everything.
You can have your culture,
your language, your food,
your music and you can still have
everything that this country offers.
Why compromise for less.
You can have everything
and keep what is your,
your roots and makes you
different and special and richer.
I,
but because I speak two languages,
I feel that I have two
different visions of the world.
When I read my books in
translation because I have
to check the translation into
English, I realized that it is,
that that language is like blood.
So personnel, it comes with
your upbringing, with your DNA.
So keep it, don't, don't forget it,
and just incorporate more and
more and it becomes a richer life.
And I, I, when I say blend,
it doesn't mean that you,
that you forget or renounced
to who you are. Not at all.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Marissa. Uh, and yeah,
thank you so much for your talk. And, um,
several times you brought up
letters like, uh, you know, how you,
you've written to your mom and,
and how you've researched, uh,
people's letters from so
long ago. Um, and, uh,
I worked in Gmail for a while here.
So you know,
a lot of data privacy and things go
to, uh, uh, about people's letters.
But my question is about,
you know, now that you have
a foundation, um, and you're,
and you're working with some of these
groups that each person has some stories
that, that they are important to,
um, to our history, right? Um,
how can we like empower
those voices? Um, you know,
do you in your foundation tell
these people like, Eh, you know,
even though this is something difficult,
like we have to write some letters,
we have to, um, make a way so that
these voices are heard, you know,
a hundred years from now,
200 years from now.
Well,
there is a program in the United States
tell your story in which they record
people. They record
migrants, people who go,
who will come here from all over the
world. And they go into this little cabin,
which they record their,
their story.
And all of those stories are
being kept somewhere and archived.
So now with all the media that
we have with all the inquiry,
if the fact that everybody's taking
selfies on, um, youtube sign,
everybody's in social media, this
is a huge way of recording. What,
what before would be lost
without the letters. You know,
I think that there are three, four up
photographs of me. When I was a child,
no one was taking pictures to take
a picture. It was a major thing.
Today you take a picture
of a hamburger for God,
everything is recorded.
We have a baby that was born in the family
and the mother every single day since
at least two or three
pictures of the baby. I mean,
I know the baby's bumped by heart.
That was impossible before. So I think
we, we don't have to worry about that.
Their voices are being
recorded better than ever.
Hi.
So actually I'm,
my question is kind of a continuation
and what you were saying is that, um,
you know, when everyone's taking a picture
and everyone's a writing stuff and,
and making movies, uh,
then it all gets lost. So,
uh, what it is that you're
a piece of technology,
the printing printing press 500 years
ago made literature is such an important
part of society and now technology
is making it disappear because uh,
you know,
the attention spans are under two minutes
were read more than ever before but
only you know,
half sentences or 140 characters.
What are your take on where
it's going in the future?
You know, I'm fairly optimistic
about the future. Um,
I don't think that technology will,
um,
will destroy culture. I
think it contributes, I need,
creates a new form of culture.
Yeah.
I think that very soon we
will start filtering more
the formation we get because
we are overwhelmed with,
with trivia and more and more,
our brain gets a little bit overloaded
with things that are not really important.
So we will learn to handle
that. It's a, it's, it's,
we are in the process of change.
Our brains have changed how our
children are born different.
When I see a three year
old working in a computer,
I mean playing games and I
can't even turn it on. It's,
it's interesting how, how humanity
adapts to new forms, you know,
and I'm very optimistic.
I don't think that the stories will be
lost or literature will disappear. We,
we all need to hear stories as
part of our acumen, human heritage,
like music.
We needed him.
And you can say it's more accessible now
because of the internet and you can get
ebooks and have them make on
you at anytime of the day.
I traveled with 20 books in
my iPad. That's great. Yeah.
Hi,
I'm Marcus left media,
like a nice to have lots of
questions. But, uh, one day,
I know you were saying that when
you write about a specific person,
a real person, um, usually
go and ask him what,
what happens with a big
character like, uh, uh, uh, Neto,
the, and about the agenda that you
wrote about. I'm here all day. I know,
I know. What I mean is, uh, do you, uh,
do you try to do in Jerusalem under
shoes and try to imagine what would they
think about the way you wrote them?
I have never written about someone that,
I mean tap someone like and I do that.
Why that person is still alive.
I'm trying to create a fictional character
out of them. I don't do that. If I,
if I'm writing about some awkward really
exists, I stick to the, to the person,
whatever the person has said I would,
I would quote that person but not invent
something that that person said because
it would be so easy to,
to prove me wrong.
I like when I,
usually my,
my historical books are from the far past.
It could be 200 years ago,
a hundred years ago.
I have a book about the
conquest of Chile 500 years ago,
but if I have someone who now I'm writing
a book in which one of the characters
is still alive,
he's 103 years old and
he's my friend and when I,
I don't,
I used him for the book as a character,
but not with his name and I have used
the information that he has given me.
Ask you gave it to me.
I didn't make up anything
about him because he's alive.
He'll be dead by the time the book
is published. But still thank you.
Out of respect. I mean, hi.
Um, some of the things I love about
your books is how they transform me to a
different time, especially in Latin
America being Latin American. Um,
my question is,
it's been a long time since you left
Chile and a lot has happened politically.
What are the major changes you
see when you get to go back there?
Chili's and other country
from the country I left,
but that has happened everywhere
in the world. I mean, um,
I left healer 40 years ago,
more than 40 years ago in 1973.
And um,
I left a country that was
under a dictatorship living
half the population living
in terror and the other half,
uh,
very happy with what was happening with
the dictatorship because they were in
control. And, and uh, 17 years later,
that's how long the dictatorship lasted.
I went back and I found
a country that still had,
was a very cautious society.
People didn't talk much at the time.
Now everything has changed. But the,
the, the fabric of the society
has changed in those 17 years.
Plus the world has also evolved.
So Chili's and other place,
I go back with this romantic
nostalgic idea of the chiller I left,
which was a poor sober country that was
struggling to find its way in the world.
And I find a totally different society
that is a neo capitalist place that sort
of doesn't fit my idea of Chile,
but, but it's still chilly.
People are the same.
So I did have one last question.
Um, are you writing another book?
I am. I just finished it like,
well, I will finish it tomorrow.
I thought I had finished it last week,
but no, I will finish it tomorrow. Um,
because I write in Spanish,
I don't have the possibility to
share the writing with anybody.
And when the book is finished,
I don't have anybody to
show it too because my mom
died and she was the one who
would read the book and,
and,
but I showed it to my brother and then
I showed it to my former editor in Simon
and Schuster who speaks Spanish.
But she left Simon and Schuster.
So still I showed her the book and so
I'm getting their input and by tomorrow I
should have a clean copy of the book.
And the book is,
I won't say historical
because it's very recent,
but it starts in 1936 in the
civil war in Spain and it,
it ends many years later. Well,
we're very, really excited.
I'm excited too because
every book is like, you know,
it's like like a bottle,
like,
like a message in a bottle that you
put in the sea and you never know who's
going to happen if someone
is going to pick it up,
if it's going to be read by someone.
I have written so many
books and still have that,
that feeling of total uncertainty.
Does it help that feeling?
Because I feel like if you were,
I don't know the other,
I don't know what were the other in gray.
I don't know that feeling. I think
we're in the same boat here at Google.
We're always aspiring
to be great and perfect,
but like we're very excited to read guys
expecting new things every day. Yeah.
Which is how I feel about the writing
that every book you have to invent
everything again, and I try not to make
the same mistakes that I've made before,
but I make new ones. There's
always new mistakes. Right.
That's always comforting. Yeah. Well,
thank you so much.
He said in the end,
it's been truly an honor speaking
with you and your very soul.
Last week we had to here to speak
with everyone. Thank you very much.